yeah so uh welcome back everyone uh
we're very happy to have faran zakala
again from
ens giving the second lecture of his
course on cisco physics and
computational high interventions
uh thank you nikki all right thank you
everyone
welcome here or welcome back if you were
here yesterday i am assuming everyone
can hear me well and you can see my
slide
right thanks so let's proceed
good this is part two uh yesterday we
had something
uh sort of statistical physics 101
uh that's a bit of a lie you know it was
one hour so there is only so much you
can do
uh still it's time to move on i will
assume that now you are
mastering all these techniques and even
though
i went quickly on them we are going to
move to maybe a more interesting part
which is to talk about uh an image um
and a sort of phenomenology that was
discussed a lot
uh in the community of you know
statistical physics but also computer
science and that was
the subject of intense activity over the
last
um let's say five six years and i will
review it and that's about uh
computational and statistical phase
transition again
i remind you that we have additional
materials not an exercise that can be
found on this address with this review
we wrote with flanker
a few years ago it's not
entirely outdated yet and also on the
topic of today's lecture
i want to mention this amazing uh set of
notes that you can find on archive
by uh alfonso bandera amelia perry and
alex
it's really really good especially if
you're not a physicist maybe you will
find
this clearer all right
so without further ado let's go
but the question i want to discuss today
is the following one how hard is it to
learn
from data that have been generated from
probabilistic model
all right so now the next this you know
the next two three four five minutes
will maybe sound pedantic uh to my
fellow panelists and for
uh many of you and it is uh certainly
pedantic but
you know this is going on youtube it's
registered so i'm trying to think to
you know to reach a broader audience
here so i want to come back to very
basic questions
so you know this is really good
questions we have data coming from
some model and we try to learn something
from them the parameter regenerated the
data we try to learn something from this
data how hard is it
okay so i'm borrowing these slides from
andrea montanari i really like them
because they carry
very well the idea so here i'm carry
catering
it's a really caricature of the
situation
but it's often useful to do so
well the answer to those questions
depends who you ask
traditionally you know if you are
thinking about statistics
and certainly that's true in the very
old days of fisher
and shannon and even before them laplace
well it's easy you know you design the
probabilistic model for data
then you try to find the best optimal
store and you
work it out and in fact there is a good
theory statistical theory that tells you
how to design good estimators for the
quantity you are trying to learn
and often you can show that these
estimators are assembled totally
asymptotically efficient and with enough
data you can solve the problem
right and in these days uh
you know you did not really care about
modeling of computation
also because this does not really high
dimensional problems you know
if the dimension is three well
exponential of three is not so big
so it's probably okay all right
now that's information turns that
of course computational complexity
theory in computer science grew up in a
very different way
it was really about computational
complexity classes
uh and you know at least at the
beginning
of course uh there was no modeling of
the data it was really a worst case
analysis you have this
model of complete universal model of
computation and you ask yourself is your
problem is in p
and p and so on and so forth because the
full hierarchy and so on but there was
no
modeling of computation so of course
this is not true anymore
there is a lot of activity in this
branch here with trying to work
for instance adversarial problem and
samia dersaya also miranda there are a
lot of
but uh you know let's leave us with the
following
data in practice are far from more
scales right we should not expect them
to be in the worst case and in fact
npr problem is solved every day in
practice
you know think neural network think
optimization of coloring problem or
styletron
so you know it's probably interesting to
ask you what is going on here
and this is uh what i will discuss today
in a limited view and the one that
emerged from
this line of work more precisely i will
look at
these two questions right so if you have
probabilistic data model
how hard is it to learn something from
them if you have unlimited computation
so that's a really information
theoretic way to learn and how can you
do if you have limited compression
resource and
let's say polynomial low polynomial
algorithm
all right so a good example is the
following one clustering
so this is a very famous example these
are uh
gene expression correlations so these
are genes
in a in corn it's actually in corn and
people are looking to the way they are
these gene are expressing
themselves in different cells and you
see that some genes explain themselves
together
quite a lot and then you can try to
cluster and it is how it look
okay so clustering is a very hard
problem
if you want to solve it the query you
have to try all the possible
combination left and you know all the
permutation
of the genes so it should be hard but
people do it in practice
so let's try to see if we can understand
this but of course we're not going to
see
to look at something but hard and what i
will discuss today will be
the following problem right so we have
um
variables so n variable and let's say
that some of them are correlated and
some of them are not
okay in this example we have four groups
of variable and i'm drawing a
adjacency matrix or graph if you want
but essentially
variables are correlated where there is
a point fireball are not correlated so
this one and this one well
it's white right and this is a model in
which
your four groups are called off variable
but are very much correlated together
while they are not correlated uh too
much with over at least less correlated
with the group
okay now of course in reality
data are not giving given to you colored
like this
you are given an adjacency matrix so
it's more like this black and white
and it's worse they are not given to you
in order
and this is actually the same matrix and
well the task of clustering
is a task of identifying the permutation
that will go from here
to here
right and well it doesn't look entirely
easy
so let's uh dig deeper so
in fact the example that i just showed
you
is an example of an instance of the
stochastic block model it's a very very
much studied problem it's actually hard
to track it down
i think it first appeared in 83 invest
paper by hollande lasker leonard
and that's the context of social
networks
and it appeared in computer science in
this very nice paper by a guy on frieza
in 89
they called it the planted something
model
and they introduced it precisely for the
same kind of question i i'm asking here
how hard is it
to find a hidden solution here
all right so here is the model more
formally with n variable
each has a sign one of the queue groups
or q colors
it's easier to think about colors so the
ti's
can take value from one to q and i is
going from one to n
and the way you work is that once you
have these colors or these groups with
assignments
you generate an adjacency matrix
according
well to this probability rules you put a
link
between i and j with probability p
t i t j so this is depending on their
colors
and the model is set up by this
probability matrix
which giving you the probability that
there is a link between group 1 and
group 1
between group 1 and q and so and so
forth
so actually it will be convenient not to
work with this
matrix but instead with this rescaled
one
right i just divide 1 over n times c so
if you want c
is just p
times n and i will work with this matrix
instead
now once you've write this the other
algebra of your graph because of course
an adjacent symmetric like this one can
be seen as a graph
is given by this formula okay
now the goal is i'm giving you the
adjacency matrix i'm giving you
the graph and you are supposed to
find back the underlying partition into
groups
all right so please try to remember this
notation for
what follows eta is a probability
that each
variable goes to one group we are going
to focus on the symmetric stochastic
block model
where we have an equiprobability so a
query each trial
each wire each node can be one of the q
group with equal probability to another
queue
same for the matrix we are going to take
a very simple case
we take a diagonal here p in and
everything
out of the diagonally spear out that
means that we have a probability to be
connected
with variable in the same group
p in or c c in divided by n
and a probability to be connected with
everyone else which is p
out p outside or if you want c out
divided by n
in that case the average degree is just
d equal one over q
c n plus q minus one c out okay so this
is the model
i'm going to focus in the rest all right
so let's start
well let's start with the information to
a answer
we have such a problem how hard is it to
find back the hidden assignment
well in theory it's not hard at all we
know precisely what is the best thing to
do
and in fact if you want for instance to
minimize the mean square error
for your estimator the best thing to do
is just to sample
uh assignment from the posterior measure
which is written here
so the posterior measure of the
assignment
possible segment ti given the graph
is given by this simple formula well
that's simple formula
simple exercise to show it so here is
what you are supposed to do well
you ask a sampling machine to output
many many configurations from this
posterior
and then you compute averages that is
what we do here so we can't how many
times
you know the variable one is in color
one how many time variable two is in
color two
we marginalize we just take the average
and that's it this is the base estimator
and it should give us uh the
means and the base overlap is also
obtained in the same way you just look
at each of the variables
and you pick up the color in which it is
more often okay so it's easy to do
except we have to sample from this
measure which
of course is not easy but let's try to
do it first
here i have done it i brought a monte
carlo markup chain for you
i run it extremely long time i use my
best computer i'm pretty sure that i'm
mixing
so visa i'm confident i'm extracting a
good
configuration from this
sampling problem and then what you are
i'm showing you is the overlap
that is the normal fraction of correct
level that i find
with this procedure for different graphs
and x by c
out divided by c in okay so
when epsilon is large well it means c it
is large so there is
more probability to be connected with
people outside but inside your group
of course if c in is large until one is
small and then you have this
very well defined cluster so it should
be easier and in fact it is easier we
see that
the overall app i find which should be
the best overlap is very large when it
is small and then it decay seems to go
close to zero
um and then in fact it goes to zero
around here
already this is a hinting at the
presence of a phase transition
all right so what do we really want to
know here what are the challenging
well we would like analytically to get
the asymptotic error we would love to
have
an analytic formula that give us this
line when the number of viable is going
to infinity
of course you would also be interested
into devising a polynomial estimator
because
well mcmc is maybe not the best thing to
do and it's not always fast
of course this is hard because this is
precisely the kind of problem we're
interested in in this
event it's a nine-dimensional
non-complex problem so it's
not easy and it's outside of the box of
you know old-fashioned
statistical learning series because we
don't have statistical consistency you
know this is really
one of these dimensional problems where
things are not
easy now of course
given the title of this series and
given yesterday a lecture you might not
be surprised that there is
maybe one good way to solve this problem
and to give a solution which is
to use what we learn in lecture one the
approach given by statistical physics
and in fact indeed statistical physics
provide us tools
to answer precisely these questions with
the replica method we saw yesterday
and is its little sister the cavity
method
so this is a problem we looked a lot
with oriental chris moore and lenka a
few years ago
and later with the bullet sphere and in
this series of paper
uh we tried to work out the solution to
the question i just asked
to you what did we find
all right here is what we found first of
all
everything depends on your degree if you
have a large average degree
things are slightly simpler so if the
degree is larger than logan
well we can actually compute the replica
solution
and it's very close to what we did
yesterday the replica solution
uh is as you know as you saw yesterday
expressed in terms of a function the
replica function or the replica
potential
that you have to maximize here it is so
you see it's a function that takes into
input
m and lambda m is a semi-definite
q by q matrix and you will have to
maximize
over this matrix so yesterday we
maximized over the scale layer but
here we have a matrix to maximize
over and we have this lambda that
appears here
and lambda is actually the signal to
noise ratio it's given by this formula
that you see here
and it seems that everything depends
only on c in minus c
out squared divided by d
all right so here it is once we solve
this problem
this maximization problem then the
replica which is a heuristic method
you saw yesterday how it works tells you
that the mutual information between the
graph
and the hidden assignment is given by
this formula lambda over 4 minus
well the value of this function
evaluated that is max
but the mean square error or sorry
the mean square row is given by the
trace or one over q
minus m star and the best overlap
is also given by a function which is
slightly complicated so you didn't write
it
but it's again a function of m star
good and what about the case where the
average degree is not large
well in that case we have to work a bit
harder
uh in that case we used actually the
cavity method but we have a very similar
result
we have a fixed point equation to solve
again and to extremize
is just that well it's certainly a bit
uglier
now if the order parameter is no more q
by q matrix
instead we have q distribution on air q
that maximizes cavity
potential okay so i'm just showing the
formula here
uh it's a functional now so you have to
uh extremize this functionality of
this set of functions uh it's of course
a bit harder to do numerically but if
you work
hard enough you can do it otherwise it's
exactly the same once you maximize it
extremize it actually well you can
compute the mutual information with the
exact same formula
and again the minimum score error or the
best overlap are given by
formulas that are directly a function
of the fixed point uh distributions that
extremize
the cavity from here all right so this
is what is
obtained with a physics style method
you saw yesterday of a work in a
nutshell
now after we did this work there was
quite a lineup
of mathematical work that followed
this prediction and expanded them
quite a bit actually and we try to prove
uh many of his results and to build on
them and to go beyond them
so the dance case is actually pretty
much under control
everything is rigorous now there have
been really long series of work
so i'm not going to read them you will
see here many of the
people interested on this problem and
who are participating
at this conference so actually this
paper here
and this paper here were written in
berkeley during my last visit
so this is nice in fact many of these
works are using the guerra interpolation
i showed you yesterday
now the sparse case is a bit more tricky
okay and maybe it's a more interesting
case uh
because it's you know if you like
community detection it's it's really uh
maybe uh closer to what you get in in
practical applications
it turns out at least the disassortative
case when sea out is larger than seen
has been proven and this is a nice work
we did
with uh i mean kojo glenn and
and when i say we did they did the
really hard part so it's a very nice
work
and we actually prove that the free
energy is correct here
it turns out there is no such proof yet
for the associative case
which is too bad because this is the one
we really care about
and then basically no work that tells
you the cavity formula is correct
in that certificate so it's still open
in fact one of the reasons this is so is
because we don't have
a working uh interpolation scheme
anyway can i ask interrupt about that so
there was a recent uh about a month ago
a mean and a bunch of co-authors
uploaded a new archive paper are you
aware of this one i
i think it claims to do the assortment
of course but if they
of course not they should uh check it
thank you okay okay so i haven't
i haven't read it carefully so i'm not
sure but it's you know yeah
it's great if they will make uh
progresses on this uh thank you
can you send the reference in the chat
yeah apparently
all right great so we see that this
thing starts to crack but anyway even
before proving
the value of the free energy many of the
you know results that we discussed have
been proven and expanded upon
and in fact while joe himself has
made amazing contribution uh
and uh the location of the phase
transition that we are going to discuss
are entirely
in particular and uh and
you know for those of you who are
interested for instance you can check
out the whole nice review of emmanuella
bay
on the topic all right so enough
reviews let's see what actually uh
the solution tells you for instance what
was
what we get from monte carlo and here is
what we get from a cavity method
so you see it works perfectly well and
we have this nice phase transition
here but for two colors a given value
the best overlap that we can get even
with
infinite computational power is zero
in other words this means that this
epsilon is larger than
the critical value which is here
asymptotically influenced it's
impossible
even the best estimator do not correlate
with the hidden assignment
so that was a very interesting phenomena
and uh in fact you can actually show
that the kind of graph you create in the
execution are contiguous with erdogan
all right so i will not go into the
definition of contiguity but essentially
it means
it's really hard to distinguish with
them with erdogan in fact there is no
estimator that can
make the distinction with probability
one
so when does this happen well
essentially
it happens when the lambda center is
larger than something you can compute
which is order q
of q okay so it's the snare
the critical ethernet gets larger if you
have more and more community
all right so there is a phase transition
this information theoretic phase
transition if you have
a large enough scenario it's fine you
can learn something
if the scenario is too small well there
is no way you are going to learn
anything from your graph
good so we have answered this question
what about the second one how are we
going to do this in practice because of
course
well i was merely discussing
infinitely long monte carlo markov chain
and we cannot do that in practice
so that was uh what was uh the question
that motivated iron friesen 89
and there have been a long series of
work who try to get better
results and to find algorithm but in
polynomial time
can output of you know a guess that is
better at the random guess it has a
finite correlation with the hidden truth
so you see here that as time goes by we
get better and better algorithm
and we start with c minus c out that is
getting smaller and smaller
but we are not quite yet at the value
that
is predicted uh by um the information
integrating threshold
so let's see what we can do so again as
i said yesterday physicists really love
iterative algorithm and in particular
for problems like this
they are really in love with belief
propagation uh
probably because one of the early
instances of belief propagation
was written by bitter and piles already
in the 20s
and if you take the initial of better
empires it's bp
like belief propagation so it really
means that
we really love it we can use these two
words and we
we are acknowledging two of the best
physicians of all time
all right so why do we like bp because
bp is exact on
graph which are three
these graphs are not really but they are
tree-like if you zoom
close enough it's very easy to see that
any finite distance
if you have a large graph coming from
the stochastic block model
you will not have loop so we kind of
hope
that something like belief propagation
will be really really good
in fact the world theory of statistical
physics of this problem
is built around the idea that you can
decompose the gibbs measure into fixed
point of bp so it's really
natural to run something like the
propagation
all right how do you write believe
propagation for this problem well this
is it
uh it's written in terms of this thing
called messages so the message is from i
uh from k to i here or from i to j
what it really means it is the
estimation of the marginals
for the colors and the assignment of s
nodes
if j was not here right
and this one k 2 i is the assignment
it's the marginals of k
if i was not here now it's very easy to
write a recursion on trees
uh telling you what these marginal
should be given these
and what this one should be given these
two and so on and so forth
and this is the formula so
basically take these two marginal here
and copy this one and so on and so forth
okay so bp runs in linear time
at least that's true on a tree on a
graph you have to make it converge it's
not always
easy it's not actually guaranteed to
converge but if you dump it
enough it apparently does so and so it's
really a polynomial algorithm right
actually linear in n
there is a bad q square that can get a
bit nasty
we have an implementation if you want to
to run it
all right so what happened if you run bp
for this problem well
this is what you get you get something
which is
basically not distinguishable from monte
carlo itself
okay this is
what we get with bp and this is what you
get from monte carlo
for a graph of degree 3 and two groups
these are four groups and the graph of
degree 16. so you know we get something
amazing so that's great it seems that bp
is solving all our problems
it persons optimal estimation in
polytime problem solved
and now we can just move to another
problem
well not quite because of course you
know if you make experiment then you
really realize that bp
sometimes fail and when it fails it
doesn't
just fail it fails spectacularly
like it doesn't beat a random guess so
there is
here one such example uh
it's an example which is a
disassortative case so
every community is not connected with
people in its own group
it's a planted coloring if you if you
want with five color
and it's very large graph one hundred
thousand nodes
and here i'm changing the average degree
now the optimal overlap we should get
information theoretically is
this one zero but it jumped
spectacularly here
i'll give you that and if we run bp
instead well here we don't find anything
better than a random guess
until we reach 16 where boom
magically we start to get the optimal
solution again so with this one region
rbp entirely failed of course once you
find it well you start to worry a bit
you check a bit what is going on with
different cases
and you realize that bp actually fails
quite often these are other examples
uh this is the dance case so here i'm
plotting the mean square error
and this is for 10 color 15 color 20
color
and here i'm writing bp but for those
who know this is more rnp
which is a dense version of
approximately
so when you increase
uh the noise or the inverse scenario
what happens is that well you go from
zero error to a finite error
and at some point you get what you have
here which is
what you will get by a random guess okay
so the line here is what we should get
information theoretically
here note that i'm not plotting one
other snr but two square over snr
why because if you run bp invest region
actually bp which are just the dots and
the crosses
and the stars is giving you the exact
same
sme mse that you would expect from the
optimal
solution so it's work but once
you reach uh q squared divided by lambda
let's snr boom bp is not better for the
random guess
so it seems that something is going on
around this value let's see now when q
squared divided by lambda is 1.
all right so i remind you that lambda s
n r is just c minus c out squared
divided by d
so what we find empirically is that bp
seems to work if and only if
lambda that is c minus n squared l by d
is larger than q
squared all right can we understand that
okay one way to understand it is to
realize that when bp
fail it's marginal or basically one of
the queue everywhere for each column
so maybe a good way to work is to say
well bp is a bit too complicated
so instead let's linearize bp around the
trivial fixed point
and see what happens to the small
perturbations we write all
messages as one of a q plus epsilon and
epsilon is a small messages and then we
can linearize
uh the billy propagation recursion but
if you do so
this is what you obtain this set of
epsilons
obey a very very simple recursion in
fact
it's just a linear recursion perhaps not
surprisingly where b
is an operator it's a d n times d n
matrices so
it's a matrix that is twice the number
of edges times twice the number of
changes
which tells you how directed edges are
connected on the graph
because of course this is what matters
for bp right once
to optimize this message i need to
remember that i take this message invest
message
and so this matrix is just the adjacency
matrix that tells you which
direct edges are connected
okay by the way it's not a symmetric
matrix all right so now we have a much
simpler object it's all linear and so
perhaps we can try to understand what is
going on
so this idea was actually proposed uh by
a group of authors myself christopher
moore canada
joe allen lanka and panzang
in 2013 and our idea was well
if we look at this matrix probably
you know they should convert to ligand
vectors
of this method so maybe we just can
forget about all these bp nonsense
and just look at drastic matrix and that
will give us an algorithm
right so it's spectral clustering
algorithm except that instead of looking
to the adjacency matrix we would have to
look to this matrix which is called the
non-beta-attacking operator
okay it's called number tracking because
it describes non-backpacking works
under the graph these two directed edges
are connected with this one
but this one is not connected with sags
so the kind of work you do here
cannot go back right they are not
backtracking that's the difference
between the adjacency operator
so if you want to check this idea what
you have to do is to work out the
spectrum of the matrix and the property
of the eagle vector
this is a bit harder than the usual
matrices largely because
it's not a symmetric matrix but it tells
that it's a good idea
so for instance this is what happens
when lambda is smaller than the
q squared there's only one value out
of a circle here by the way there is a
circle because the eigenvalues of this
matrix are complex
and they are all in the circle of square
root
square root of d except one which is
actually
entirely trivial okay it's not collected
in hidden signal
and what happens when you cross uh
q square when the snr is large enough
well you have an additional eigenvalue
that comes out and you can
show this is what we did in this paper
and
later on that was proven uh in this
series of work by uh
bordenav
[Music]
who generalized it to more than two
communities
well you can show that the eigenvectors
connected to their secondary
is actually correlated with the ground
truth all right so
that's nice because looking at the
number packing operator allow us to
understand what's going on with bp
and once you know this you can also
forget bp all together and just work
with the spectrometer
so this is the kind of overlap you get
when you look at the
[Music]
eigenvector associated with this guys
you have a good correlation with those
guys with char
you know color one and those were
colored
all right now we have been able to make
progress
you know we have this matrix we can
actually probably work
but it proves that it's working better
than random at least when
lambda is less than q squared now we
understand why bp works when lambda is
larger than q squared is because bp is
basically starting
you know it's the first step uh when his
message starts to be a bit different
from one of the queue it's following the
undertaking operator so of course if
this doesn't work
it will never work and it does a lot of
interest in itself actually
you know it's improved drastically over
standard spectral mechd and there are
many other applications
for this thing that goes beyond what i'm
discussing today and
that will be subject to another story
but at least now we understand what is
going on all right so let's summarize
well everything is not dependent on the
snr if the center is large enough
larger than you know q or q then it's
possible to do something
before no way you can learn something
from your graph
now we have this region between q q and
q squared
where we don't know how to solve the
problem and certainly
belief propagation and longer hacking do
not work
and finally when the snr is large enough
larger than q squared
we have this algorithm that works
perfectly well and we are all happy
good so this is an example of an
impossible hard easy pattern
here we have a statistical transition
where it becomes statistically possible
to make a learning but the computational
transition when it becomes only possible
in practice
is here and we have a statistical to
computational gap
well of course you may say well that's
not quite a convincing story
because i just told you that bp doesn't
work here but maybe you don't agree with
me that this is a good algorithm
and you can try other things in fact
yeah what about other algorithmic
approach maybe
it's possible to have a good algorithm
that is efficient and that work
perfectly well in this region
so we tried there have been many
attempts to beat vesque squadration to
find the polynomial algorithm that gives
you probably
or even empirically a positive
overlap with the truth for lambda
smaller than q squared
of course monte carlo simulation fail
you realize that if you run monte carlo
starting
from a random initial condition at
random
well it seems that you have to run it
exponential time
to start to see something good so it's
not good
well if you go to the computer science
department people will start to work
with the summer school hierarchy and
there have been a long line of work
on this problem including many of the
people attending the conference and it
failed
exactly at the same point at q squared
so that's very interesting it seems to
say that really there is something deep
around this moment
people try to use neural nets everything
you know everyone is trying to learn
neural net this day and they say you
know
let's ask a neural net to learn the best
method well if you try graph neural
network
to invert this problem to find the
assignment
in a stochastic block model it fails
to beat the q square threshold in fact
it's interesting
uh this method seems to just relearn the
number tracking metrics
which maybe is interesting because it
means we are maybe not so clever and to
when we designed it or maybe we were
very clever because you need a huge
amount of computational time to do it
while we did it just talking between
friends
we tried even quantum annealing at some
point even we don't have a
computer well we have quantum replica
methods and quantum cavity method so we
try to see what's going on and we
you know we show that it doesn't work
even if you have a quantum computer
so we don't know anything
so far that worked in poly time in the
art region we don't know of any method
that actually is able to
put something that correlates with the
truth in this region
so you know at this point we feel
obliged to make a bold conjecture
maybe this is hard for all polytechnic
algorithms
maybe not and what will be very
interesting is to have a very clear-cut
definition of a set of algorithms that
will not work here
hey hey florent this is this is sam can
i just make a
clarification that i don't think we can
actually prove this uh particular sum of
squares lower bound
yet we have uh some reasonable evidence
for it but it would be a really great
open problem
good point um so that's you know that
will we need to add this one in the list
of problems that nike and celia are
asking
yes thanks
good well anyway you know proving that
it stopped here is one thing what would
even better is to beat it
it would be amazing to find something
that goes here
now that was all about community
detection and maybe you say
you know who cares about this problem
but the point is this seems to happen
all the time
in most of the problems that we are
devising and trying to study we find
something like this
this is a variant that people like a lot
called the planted clique problem
here what you try to find is a set of
fully connected variables here a click
inside a random graph
here it's a random graph it's a g and p
with a
p equal one now so the probability to be
connected with someone else's one
except for a click of size k okay
of course here the click is easy to find
but this is a perturbed you know the
permuted
graph and you don't find it so easily
now as far as we know
it's impossible to find the click if the
size of the click is smaller than
something which is
for their login because naturally clicks
or further login occurred
in gnp one off
now people have been trying hard to find
good algorithm
and they all seems to uh at least for
you know click polynomial time
they seem to stop to fail around the
square root of n
so here we don't know of any algorithm
and here we have you know various
myriad of algorithms that work here
now i want you know to give us last
example
because it's interesting and it's it is
connecting to the lecture of yesterday
which is a balanced asymmetric
communities case okay so it's community
detection
with two communities of densely
connected groups
but one is small and the one is large
okay so there is a size rho n and one
minus rho n
and to make the problem difficult we are
forcing the graph to be a regular graph
with a fixed connectivity so every point
has the same connectivity on its
neighbors
so that makes it very hard to
distinguish between the big group and
the small group by just looking at their
local connectivity
if you do this here is a phase diagram
it's very interesting so here we have
row
so one half is just community detection
with two groups
when row is going to zero well you start
to have a huge group and an infinitely
small one
and everything in between is here now
everything seems to depend only on this
parameter delta which is an effective
noise or inverse ascendant if you want
which is p
one minus p so p i remind you was uh
the
fixed connectivity of average
connectivity of the graph was pn
and what is going on is the following
when the noise is too large
well we have this phase here where it is
impossible to learn
when the small when the noise is small
or it's a scenario is large
it's very easy to learn something
correlated in fact a spectral algorithm
would work
and since this is a dense graph you
don't even need the backtracking matrix
you can just
take the adjacency matrix and you have
this thing called the bbp
transition that will work interestingly
you have this region here
which is a hard region here
so here we know that it is statistically
possible
to return uh a good guess
but we don't know if any algorithm that
work okay
and certainly uh really propagation
doesn't work
now i want to make the connection with
what i told you yesterday
so the nice thing is that for this dense
graph the free energy can be written in
a very short way
this is it actually this is not the free
energy it's the mutual information that
this is the same
except that you have to minimize it so
it is a replica material information
it's a formula that depends on the
scalar
m and its minimum is the actual mutual
information
this is proven so depending on the value
of the noise
this function that's replica potential
look like that like that or like that
and the minimum is changing so here it's
very small noise
the minimum is here this is error it's
small
when we increase the noise while the
minimum is
going to position where the error is a
bit larger
and secondly when you go from here to
here there is two minima
boom and this guy becomes a minima and
the error they start your height fast
and and when the noise increase again
well at this point
it's really bad right so the interesting
thing
uh that is that you can just see this
from looking at the
replica free energy you can actually see
its minimum change
now why am i speaking about this problem
well because in that case belief
propagation can be written
in a very much simpler way which is
called as proximate methods passing
and it's just an iterative algorithm
which you already saw yesterday
okay and i will not go into detail but
the important thing about the
approximate misaspecting is that as we
discussed yesterday
it's an algorithm but really just trying
to find the fixed point of the replica
potential so if you ask
what is the overlap between the
estimation given by inp
and the truth and you call this m of t
well the overlap is following at each
time
this expression which is just the fixed
point expression is trying to climb
uh well to climb it's trying to find the
fixed point of the replica potential
now why is this interesting it's
interesting because you can understand
you can read off
the behavior of imp just by looking at
the function
now if the function look like that
so yesterday i was trying to climb the
replica potential but today is the
replication information which is just
the constant minus it so i'm trying to
descend it so i'm trying to minimize it
if it looks like that well it's easy you
know an
algorithm will probably do something
like this and stop here
so that kind of potential is good for
imp and mp actually achieves
mmc now if the potential look like that
instead
when you start for larger
well you iterate and you will get stuck
here
so when the replica potential looks like
this and develop a secondary minima
well often it means that your algorithm
will have problems and in fact this is
how we can read off the behavior of imp
and belief propagation directly from the
potential it's very practical
in that case we don't achieve mmc here
we achieve it because of course
this bad minima is still here but now
the bad minima is actually the best one
we can do so
okay so that kind of situation where the
replica potential
has to bump and develop local minima and
maxima
is where we we are expecting trouble
all right now these were just examples
of the stochastic block model and the
planted clinic
but of course you know the last 10 15
years
we have found pretty much the same
behavior
almost everywhere you know and it's sbm
and plotted click we found it in
generalized er model
in some sample model of neural network
and then splattered semantics implanted
constant satisfaction
people knew about these in ldpc error
correction
they know that bp doesn't achieve a
capacity
it's the same in sparse pci gaussian
mixture clustering and so on and so on
and so forth and like the list goes on
and like i will speak about this again
for two more lectures so i will not
spoil it too much
and we had a very nice uh workshop uh
organized by sam andrea and david two
years ago
about this topic in stock all right my
time is almost
up but this is pretty much what i wanted
to tell you
uh which are what are the consequences
of the formalism we saw yesterday
and where do we stand now now before
giving up the floor i want to make two
final remark
first one is about the physics intuition
why is it so why is it that
the fact that the potential has to you
know has developed this nasty bad local
minima
how does it have to do with the fact
that everything seems to fail
and the short answer is i don't know uh
but let's try to see if we can give a
physics intuition
now physicists are really really used to
his potential and their maximization in
fact
our wall understanding of condensed
matter theory
and phase transition in the world is
based about this we look at these
we compute these for materials and
nature is just like
us here nature is trying to minimize
free energy or to maximize
entropy and so you have this function
and it moves locally and it's trying to
do something
now if you study your
phase transition you will know for
example the diamond is not the true
minimum
of the free energy or it's not the
maximum of the local entropy
actually diamond is a local maxima
you know nature try hard to find the
ground state of a set of carbons
and it's stuck in this diamond case but
if you give it exponential time you know
and you wait
one or two you know twice the time since
the big bang
well eventually it will reach this point
and the true equilibrium will be
graphite powder so diamond
is not eternal actually it's external in
practice
but not statistically if you want so we
are used to this we call this first
order transition
and we know that there is basically
nothing much you can do in this case
so it's very tempting to think that well
that's it we have a nice attrition
there is a heart phase because there is
a barrier in the free energy potential
constraint at the distance from the
solution
right you remember i introduced this
idea yesterday of the constraint free
energy
right and that's it you know we go here
and we never go
there and it's very tempting and in fact
there is a lot of interesting activity
in mathematics that use this for
instance you can prove
that if you are here and if you try to
make sampling with local monte carlo
algorithm
it will take exponential time to go here
it's actually one of the way you prove
this thing
in mathematical physics so maybe if it's
hard to sample starting from here it's
no wonder that it's hard
to find this thing and we really loved
this idea and with chris moore
we we thought a lot about it then i
remember with ahmed we spent a lot of
time trying to prove that this is
actually what is going on
um and one of the reasons that this is
tempting to to use this is that we have
a selection that i told you yesterday
right the replica symmetric potential is
an upper bound
on the constraint free energy with
equality at the max
right so this is how the free energy
looks
from the replica point of view and of
course it's good
at the max we will prove this
right so is it true is it true
that secondary minima appears at the
same value of the snl in the two
function
because these are not the same function
remain you know remember that inp
is not claiming the constant free energy
inp and bp are climbing the replica
symmetric one
so they stop to work when you have this
minima or maxima appearing
in the replica symmetric function so
maybe this maxima appears at the same
time in the replica symmetric function
and it's a true constraint
well it turns out that this is not true
so i believed this
and it's just plain wrong so this
explanation
uh is wrong this is not true um in fact
that was shown uh in a in a very nice
work last year by
lanka with fabrizio
such situation exists where
the replica symmetric free energy is
nice has only one maxima here
while the true free energy constrained
to a
distance m as this local maxima
that means the following and you know
i'm really personal by this
if you increase the noise or decrease
snr
and you ask yourself well when does the
local maxima appear
in the truth constraints energy well it
happens somewhere
when does it appear in the replica
symmetrical energy it happens later
now the point is that message passing
work in this world region
so thinking that when the true
function developer local maxima is the
moment where you have a real problem
for finding a statistical solution
is entirely wrong and uh i was surprised
by this
uh but that seems to be true what seems
to matter is not the true constraints
energy but the replica symmetric one
and that seems to say that there is
something really fundamental
about imp and bp which is a line of
thought which is performance by andrea
montanary and
in the group uh in fact he was able to
show that
in some limited class of algorithm imp
is the best but still
you know i'm not really satisfied but
what is going on here and i i found this
very interesting
all right the second remark that will be
uh
short i hope is does this always work
when i do bp and inp
those you know for any problem i can
really run them
is it true that they always give me the
true you know
threshold for hardness uh of course not
we need to be sure that impbp are the
right tool for the job and how do we do
this
well first of all and this is to answer
a question from
nike i believe yesterday scaling matters
okay no that's when those selling was
never we need to use imp
tap vpn replica in cases when it makes
sense and for instance we want the free
energy to have a correct limit
when you take the limit of the free
energy and going to infinity to have a
finite limit
why because you know and by the way you
remember that in lecture one i carefully
design
my cost function with a n here so that
the limit exists
and uh i think sam asked me once why do
i have this np minus one somewhere
i have to do this if i want to be able
to make this computation
now why is it fundamental because the
world
cradle the world belief or physicist is
that what you do
here is decomposables mind measure into
many fixed points
of tap inp bp or whatever
you know but this message passing
algorithm their fixed points
correspond to a probability measure and
if you find all of them
you have the full probability measure
this is really what all the physics
methods are using
this is really the important thing now
that means that the fixed point of this
algorithm should be
correct and that happens only if you are
scaling things properly asymptotically
by the way this is not some physics
mumbo jumbo you can actually prove this
there is this nice paper by amin kojo
glow and and will perkins who actually
show that you can decompose the gibbs
measure and well escape problem
on random graphs into collection of
measures that
correspond to fixed point of bp and you
can do the same
on fully connected problems and that's
due to uh
antonio and akash so we we need to have
this fixed point of imp and tap mvp to
make sense
now one case where they don't make sense
is transfer spike model
okay so the way we set up the problem is
as follow
consider the following tensor so we have
x0 it's a vector
and dimension now we take its transfer
product
okay so now it's order p tensor of rank
one
and i'm multiplying by well this term do
not matter but
certainly i'm divided by n to the power
p minus one over two and this is really
due to have a
nice limit in the physics sense now this
is a
order p rank one tensor but i'm not
giving you this one i'm giving you a
noisy version
where i'm polluting every
component of the tensor by random
gaussian ied noise with variance delta
now what is going on well if you try
from the tensor to find back the vector
well you can try to apply all our tools
and
here is the main theorem that we have
there is a replica of key energy that
you have to maximize blah blah blah blah
blah
and again the maximizer is giving you
the minimalist okay so it's the same
story all over again
you can write message passing this is
how it looks uh
it has been written in that case by um
and you have a state evolution so you
can also track what state what the
message does
same story over again so what is going
on well
in a nutshell this is what is going on
for this problem when the snr
is increased or when the noise is
reduced you go from an impossible phase
where it's impossible
to find the spike to
a phase where it's possible
statistically if you have infinite
computational power to find the spike
and we can compute exactly at which
value of delta or whatever delta this is
going on it depends only on the rank
of uh uh of your uh
hidden uh tensor and these are the
values
that you find now what is perhaps more
interesting
is that if you try to run imp for this
problem and that was uh
discussed by amin richard on the
montanari you see that it's really
really not working quite well in fact
you have to go really on the right of
this picture here
to go to you know snr which are of order
n to the p minus two
at this value of the snr all the
approximations you do in statistical
physics don't
make sense at all so there is no reason
to think that imp is really doing the
job
at least you know from the physics point
of view
now fine maybe that means that this is
hard here and
easy here but we know of better
algorithm
and in fact we know that you know
working with
sdp and also with tensor unfolding
we have algorithm that works way before
imp
all right again this is perhaps not so
surprising
inp is no reason to be really good here
because
the statistical physics approach which
tells you well we need to work with and
decompose into
states at a fixed point that will behave
well doesn't make sense
now why because belief propagation
is only the first step of a full
hierarchy of approximation
you start with mean field then you have
bp and then you have merged things
it turns out that in all the problems we
are looking at in general
this approximation you know this iraqis
stop
after bp so you stop at order two and bp
is fine
once you go out of bp comfort zone
well bp doesn't work anymore you have to
take more and more terms
and this is called the kikushirashi in
physics there is something equivalent of
the plague hierarchy
let us discuss in this very you know
nice paper by hiroki kikushi in in 51st
in the physics literature
so for wellscape problems the hierarchy
stop at bp
for this whole problem it doesn't so
there is no reason
that you know we would believe that bp
works so
my belief was that there was no way to
use kikushiroki because it was
too hard uh it turns out i was wrong
but i will not go into detail if you
want to know more about how to redeem
the statistical physics suppression
unleash the full power of the
kikushiraki well there is
uh conveniently enough a talk by ahmed
that will be a first day
at 1pm and uh he will go uh
and discuss his amazing work with alex
and chris uh using this approach right
all right i think i'm really uh eating
my
limit of time so i thank all of you for
listening to me i will
leave the floor to lenka i told you what
i wanted to tell you
maybe a last point i just moved to epfl
recently
uh i'm starting in one week and
we are starting a group here if you want
to work in this amazing place with
that kind of amazing view this is the
montblanc here
well write me a mail we are looking for
a talented postdoc and students
on these topics and also mediocre
and with us thank you everyone for your
attention
okay thank you so much do we have any
questions
so maybe i will start with a question
actually i think i missed the story
about the
constrained free energy and amet is also
here
so i was hoping that the two of you
could say a bit more about that
uh i don't know i meant do you want to
say something or should i
uh yeah i can say something um so
for the model let me let me put back the
slides so that
you know it feels like that we are
connected sure
this one is nice
please oh uh you want this
fine yeah um uh yeah so for the model
that i worked out which is the spiked uh
the spikes matrix model which is
a maybe a disordered version of the
random easing model that
that flower has has showed um
so you can do basically the same
interpolation calculation
and once so you can do it either for the
full free energy or for a
constraint free energy with a parameter
m that you can choose that you can just
fix as a variable
um and what happens is just really an
algebraic trick
so basically when you do the
interpolation then the
the the error that integral the
derivative that shows up along the inter
the interpolation path when it's
defoliate free energy it's positive
so that you get a bound on the right
direction but
if you constrain the free energy to have
overlap
m then basically one of those terms that
show up in the in the derivative will go
away because you just
fixed the frame you basically killed it
you
you have a term that has an overlap
minus m to the power two
and since you've already constrained the
overlap to be exactly m then that term
goes away
and it turns out that now the dominant
terms are other terms that that are not
that one and they turn out to be
to have the negative to to have the
opposite sign so that you can have an
inequality in the other direction
and so that's how you bridge the gap
between the upper and lower bounds
so there is a i can send the paper
we have a small note that explains this
idea for the for the spikes wigner model
and it's a very straightforward
computation to do but it's the
the main thing is it's really just an
algebraic trick
yeah so the constrained free energy it's
uh it's a system of two replicas that
you have
yeah right so so for the planted model
so you can have that or
for the planted model you can just have
a system with one replica
combined with the spike with the planted
solution and you can strain that overlap
i see and is it is the intuition that
it's
it should be the same as the the
unconstrained but it's better
concentrated or
uh no so uh it has the same kind of
concentration it's just when you
interpolate it
when you try to do the same query
interpolation then the
the interpolation path has a different
sign so basically you go in a different
direction
so because one of those terms that
showed up in the in the interpolation
will go away and then the sign will flip
magically so there is a computation it's
difficult to explain on slide on
like this on zoom but there's a
computation that you have to do yeah
okay thanks a lot there's another
question in the chat so one of the
uh someone asked is there a physical
interpretation of the replica symmetric
potential
uh yeah
i don't know can you see the q a
i'm looking at it i'm not sure i
understand the question
sorry is the q a on zoom or
yeah it's on zoom so the question is
is there a physical interpretation of
the replica symmetric potential i think
as a function of m and whatever other
parameters that you well
uh unfortunately
not a physical one right i mean we like
to think about the replica symmetric
potential
as best object as a true potential
uh with a fixed uh m
but this is wrong you know it's just a
bound on it
um so you know
it's not clear what it actually means
this object
now there is an algorithmic
interpretation
of the replica symmetric potential and
that in my opinion
is really uh the interesting thing about
inp
impc is an algorithm is really just
climbing the replica symmetric potential
and i think this is interesting because
it gives us a relation
between an iterative algorithm
and the replica symmetric potential
which you know is
is surprising but the algorithm is
connected to the replica symmetric
potential
value of m and not to the constraint
potential
it's really connected to the replica one
and that is you know in my opinion
something interesting
flora i have a question about this uh
new finding that you said so these
these two functions are not equal but
one can can be concave and the other one
can develop local minima
so that's that's exciting right um yeah
like so the one that we would expect is
physically relevant
is uh vc feed yes
so so what's going on there i have no
ugly idea you know i mean it's
i agree right this is is the true one is
uh
is one uh it's actually a true free
energy right so you would expect that
if you have a problem in the true free
energy you have a problem
but no this is wrong imp seems to be
clever
imp is not attempting to climb the truth
energy imp
is trying to claim the replica symmetric
energy
and there seems to be this this case
that the replica symmetric energy is
nice
while the you know the real one is nasty
um i was really i was as surprised as as
as you when uh you know i i learned this
from from this paper
now the point is that you know people
you know you can complete with replicate
away
the constraint free energy but you have
to use replica symmetry breaking
it's very interesting my drawing is
really bad here essentially you know the
replica symmetric so if you compute
the replica symmetric sorry if you
compute with the replica method this
object
this part is given by the replica
symmetry and all this region here the
non-convex region
requires some replica symmetry breaking
so it's you know it's
it's kind of a complicated case and uh
that's essentially uh the kind of studio
that we're doing here
of course heuristically with the replica
method but if i'm not mistaken i think
there's some paper
by dimitri pachenko who is
trying how to you know is actually
proving how to compute
this thing with replica symmetry
breaking techniques
it's probably you know doable to prove
uh that this situation exists by the way
that would be interesting to prove
unless exist right
because it shows that there exist
situation
where if you start at random and you do
an algorithm which is you know not
particularly clever
it's just a simple iterative algorithm
inp you find something good
while if you start here you know you you
run your monte carlo your monte carlo
will fail immediately
i mean i found it's really surprising i
was expecting you know the kind of mcmc
to work
as good as uh as uh as imp
and it you know it's not true and i
don't know why
it's certainly not intuitive
so by the way this paper i think they do
this in
a spiked answer model as well
there's a and someone has raised their
hand yeah okay
thank you nick uh hi florence thank you
for the for the talk
um i just have a question uh related to
going back to nike's question on the
constrained uh free energy i just
i need to look at the paper that you
have with ahmed but um
i'm trying hard to see we'll stop who's
talking here and i don't see anyone oh
it's uh it's christmas it's uh christmas
uh thank you ladies
okay i i don't have a video somehow yeah
so oh yes i see this
okay but i see your name now good yeah
yeah yeah so
uh so that is very interesting that i i
need to look their paper with ahmed but
if i understand it correctly then the
constraint free energy is always a lower
bound to the
replica symmetric energy is this true uh
well
you know you have to uh you know
it's amazing but sometimes i work with
log z and sometimes minus log z
but okay let's say that i see right okay
okay okay so so it gives
it gives it gives one side but but let
me ask you that so so i
understand yes i think that this is this
is always true
that the replica uh solution
whatever you know even the one lsb two
sb three usb for usb and so on and so
forth
will be larger than the true one uh
in fact the way we compute things is to
take this function
and break the symmetry until it stops
moving
then proving it in full generality is
another story
of course but i think this is always
true as a replica
the potential is a bound on the
constrained potential yes i see
so so this is not proven but do you have
some intuition of
when it fails so when replica symmetry
is not true
what would fail in the proof that you
have for example for the beginner case
i'm trying to oh very good that is very
easy so
uh okay the the proof i use
so i yeah you know this is a bit
annoying because of course
the cases i presented yesterday were
entirely trivial
so it's harder but anyway
so at some point when you do this
interpolation um
you you have something like
q or m minus some of the variable
divided by n
and this is squared inside the bracket
and you need to send this to zero
and the way you send this additional
term to zero is by proving the
concentrate
okay these overlaps should concentrate
and if they concentrate then you send
them to zero and then you say fine my
guerrilla interpolation is equal to
the truth now what is failing in the
proof
uh is precisely this replica symmetry
breaking
exactly means that these overlaps do not
concentrate to a single value
so at this point the proof stopped to
work because actually you cannot prove
it concentrate
so you have to make a different
integration path and you know you have
to try to see finally
maybe it will concentrate to a more
complicated function and then you can
try to prove this
and so on and so forth but really you
know what breaks down is this
concentration uh replica symmetry making
is all about overlaps
not concentrating to a single value
okay thank you
are there other questions okay if not
then thank you so much
laurent and uh lenka will continue
the course tomorrow uh we have a short
coffee break now and then we'll be back
at
uh uh in about 15 minutes for
for the next talk